nfl on fox reporter and also uh the
clothing line whereby aaron andrews is
available
at fanatics.com or nflshop.com
right now for you to show off your
phantom aaron andrews of fox
back here on the rich house show it has
been too long aaron andrews how you
doing
too long and also i'll plug the ncaa
line we have
with your michigan wolverine um
available
i'm gonna do does your lovely wife does
she
does she cheer for michigan or what are
we what does she say oh god no
uh what she does what she what what
susie does
frequently aaron um is stand there
and leave me alone in the ohio state uh
pit of misery
and then come back in about 10 minutes
later and it's a 30-point worst deficit
and i get the oh
honey not again like i get that um but
she's a columbia lion do you have any
columbia gear
aaron you know what not
[Laughter]
we didn't get that approval yet uh
nope not that one uh we're getting there
how are you
i am doing great it's too bad that your
your line wasn't uh available when uh
you were supposed to wear
uh florida gator gear because my
wolverines beat your gators in the ncaa
tournament it's too bad that wasn't
available back then yeah aaron oh yeah
it always comes down to michigan and
florida either in basketball or some
lame bowl
i was telling brady that i i don't know
at some point in the off season he
tweeted something and it was like a
sunset of orange and blue and i was like
perfect gators and he's like wow
yeah we just can't get out of our own
way michigan and florida sometimes huh
well it was bad news for my wolverines
and a couple of bowl games uh
ago and but but tom if i'm not mistaken
made
his final uh appearance as a michigan
wolverine
destroying florida and urban meyer
uh before he went into the pros and
still everybody ignored him
even though he set records that i do
believe rex grossman eventually beat
in that orange bowl if i'm not mistaken
yeah that's the one that is the one rich
i had a great time on this show thanks
so much
no no no um what i appreciate about this
show
it's not on a zoom call so you don't
care what i look like right now i mean
what has happened to everybody in
quarantine that we need now to look at
each other i don't need that
i know i'd see what well what if if you
were on is it what does the uh
aaron andrews uh office look like what
does the
the andrews cave look like it's pretty
sexy um
it is more my husband's uh man cave that
i then once we got married and i you
know came to that
moved to the house i put a desk in we
had to move over some of the photos of
the 2012
2014 king championship oh that's great
you're at the white house here's my
picture of me and big poppy
[Music]
right no it's good we have it perfectly
lit in the back is our
is you know one of the bars in our house
and his jerseys and some pictures of him
doing a face off against
eiserman and then our peloton is to the
left so
it's not bad we've uh you know our
laptops are elevated so you get the high
angle
and we've lit it pretty well but yeah
the office has turned into an absolute
disaster down there everybody's got to
show off their office settings i guess
these days
aaron andrews here on the rich eisen
show your office this weekend was the
superdome what was it like doing your
gig in a pandemic
in an empty st an empty superdome that
you normally have to
uh struggle to hear what you're thinking
because it's so damn loud what was that
like for you
no i yeah that is a game where my dad is
constantly texting me before you know
whenever i'm at the superdome and he
said make sure you put that mic close to
your mouth
you know i i can't imagine how loud it
is rich i
and listen we're all so happy to be back
we'll play however you know we can but
it was bizarre i mean i had my head down
for a minute getting
everything ready to go for my first hit
and i missed the bucks running out i
mean i wanted to see tv lead them out
here we go
um because there's no noise and then
i i i just said to joe and troy on a
conference call this is what it reminded
me of
back in the day when i was in elementary
and middle school and i was on a dance
troop and yes i was in the back row
because i was five
eight when i was in third grade which
you know is the reason why i have the
posture that i have
we'd always have to go perform at the
state fair
and nobody's there except my mom and
some of her friends you know that had a
few cocktails of her cheering
here they are the bsda dance troupe and
my mom's like
whoa that's what it sounded like when
drew brees in the city
turned out it was bizarre wow yeah it
was like my mom and her three friends it
was really weird
so uh what is the sound in the stadium i
mean we're hearing sound
um you know on the broadcast and i'm not
mistaken
i think fox in that broadcast even uh
played some booze when a call went
against the saints
and i'm like that's that's that's real
that that's something that was
act that would actually have happened
but what are you hearing what are you
hearing in the in the stadium
yeah i think that was a chimera play um
nothing i mean
sean payton said it perfectly to us
before we got to the stadium they
practiced with it he goes
it kind of sounds like a lame cocktail
party
so we thought all right what does that
sound like and then they turned it on
and you got a little startled and you
thought oh oh yeah this is a lame
cocktail party
it's just like a weird little buzz but
it's not loud
i mean when brady threw his first
interception and he screamed
you know he threw two f-bombs you could
hear it so well
um you i mean it was unbelievable you're
like oh my gosh did that make it on air
of course it did
um i you know i can't be on the field
but i heard
the um the talking back and forth to
guys to opposing players
is so clear you can hear it all i wish i
could
um yeah i mean another example is
sometimes they would pump in like a song
i think they played like usher once they
were like bam boom
boom boom and i just yelled yeah and i
totally forgot that the players could
hear you
because there's no [ __ ] bend over to
the front and touch your toes i mean i
was like oh my gosh okay
um yeah it's just it's just weird but
again thankful
we're having games this thursday i don't
like the way your poll questions going
but we do have the browns and the
bengals
six to six thousand fans are going to be
there so i'm interested to see what
that's like
well before we get into this i don't
hear what is is on the tv
in that stadium so that was a long way
of answering that no no no no
it's great aaron andrews here on the
rich eisen show and we'll get to your
clothing line in a second
but uh how do how can you do your gig if
you you you can't get on the field i
mean like
you're normally you're trying to you're
trying to suss out so much
how can you how can you suss up when
when you're not allowed due to
protocols on the on the field it's a
bummer but
you know there's a lot of prep before
like i'm after i get off of you i'm
going to talk to a couple of brown
players
you don't the thing you miss the most is
the pre-pre-game warm-up where you can
walk out on the field
either on their headphones so you don't
get that
we are still thank god you know the
league is helping us we are still able
to talk to the coach at the half which i
think is huge
honestly i mean we're in we're in
contact with with the pr down on the
field
if you wanted to scream to someone and
try to get a reaction pre-pregame you
probably could because they can hear us
it's just we're all making adjustments
right it's a big bummer but
i'm so glad we're back to work aaron
andrews here on the rich housing show
ask aaron the poll question go for it
let's see
what our two senses here all right aaron
who should be panicking most
after week one browns cowboys eagles
vikings
what do you think i mean i know the
browns are winning
i just i think because i'm reading all
these articles right now about
already after week one there's so much
worry about this connection between
baker and odell
um their lines banged up going into this
you know they're without their starting
linebacker jacob phillips is now hurt i
would say them right now
hopefully they can turn it around on
thursday night i know i
by the way fantastic uh plug for for the
game that again you're gonna
and by the way uh just so you know uh
everyone out there this is a game that's
exclusively on nfl network so that's not
a fox thing that
aaron was not trying to look for
something extra in her paycheck right
there
uh this is exclusively on nfl network on
on thursday night
but this is big i mean you are not wrong
i mean if the browns start this
this season oh and two with two losses
in five games
uh and two within division that is
significant certainly
certainly with the way that they got
beat up by the ravens and the way that
the steelers looked last night that
would be
significantly problematic for them yeah
and then you you think about a joe
burrow walking in a rookie quarterback
beating this group that you know
we're talking in the off season not as
much obviously as last year but then you
think about it and we were just
you know discussing it all of us on the
phone about tom
and aryans and again how it looked like
a pre-season game
and stuff stefanski didn't have a lot of
time you know with this browns team as
well so
this is interesting i mean this whole
scenario is crazy it's wild
when will teams start looking like
themselves you know
and and i was just saying i i mean i
haven't even unpacked my suitcase from
sunday because i'm not used to being in
this
whole you know routine again and this
browns team has to turn around and play
um you know on thursday after again a
really weird off season
a lot of guys are injured right now here
we go week two already
and so what did you glean uh being as
um you know i guess immersed as you
possibly can be
with the covid with the bucks with this
team that has
i think they're winning the super bowl
at least i predicted it uh i don't know
you know what to make of what i just saw
other than the fact that it's just gonna
take some time
but what did you glean talking to
everybody there about
uh gelling and what they expect
first of all that defense is awesome i
mean even that young secondary they
looked great
and i mean michael thomas was held in
check so that was really encouraging
because i didn't know if they would
you know they had a rookie obviously
starting out there and i didn't know if
he would light them up if drew would
um there is a sense of urgency and that
is brought on when tom is there
now um you know and he had said to us
tom did
look i mean there's gonna be things we
learn in this game that we like and that
we don't like and
and we're just gonna have to grow
throughout the whole thing um
that line better protect him i did get a
little worried a couple of times when he
hit the deck the other thing is
i'm interested to see how some of these
receivers react because
you know tom i know tom things got real
on sunday on that flight back it wasn't
the good old hey let's go to the you
know the high school and show them
all around right right uh mike evans
come sit next to me and this is what
we're doing and this is what i'm seeing
and you need to learn godwin here we go
he loves that scottie miller just i mean
i know we talked about it on our
broadcast but he said to us
in the game or in in our conference call
a lot of people won't know who he is
going into this season they will at the
end of this season he loves that kid
aaron andrews here on the rich eisen
show all right before i send you in the
rest of your tuesday which i appreciate
you're spending with us
now that uh you know you're you're
traveling all over the country right now
uh let's talk let's talk about uh where
by aaron andrews um
you know no i look this is when you get
the nfl to say okay here's some marks
and logos let's make a business deal
that's significant
um oh yeah what have you how did you how
did you pull
how did you pull that one off eric how
did you do it well listen i mean we've
been trying to do this for the last five
six years i kind of thought there was a
white phase for it i
i thought there were women out there you
know i i was a woman as
i still am a woman um i was you know a
person as i rooted for my husband
with the kings i was looking for
something that i could wear to the games
and cheer for them and then
you know obviously go get a drink
afterwards or go to dinner we wanted to
make a kind of a fashion line that you
could wear
everywhere anywhere not just you know at
tailgates or on monday nights and
thursday nights and sundays
kind of make it a staple in your closet
and we had a real soft launch last year
and we
we crushed it and we uh our 2020 line
came out
um last week and i styles are going fast
and we're pumped up and we just signed
on with ncaa and the nba as well
so we're very excited about it i'm just
trying to get into your world to be so
successful i'm just trying to be
the female rich eisen you know what i
mean well you know what erin
um i don't know how to quite handle that
one um
i think you're doing just fine in in
your own right um
fanatics.com and nflshop.com i'm waiting
to see what the
where what would the whereby re look
like
uh it would have to be like a like a
cardigan
uh with a logo or a sweater or something
like that definitely a sweater situation
i mean
quarters he was a turtleneck guy but you
know you look great
you could do ties i could do that you
know
button down um shirts that don't wrinkle
because you're at the desk all day i
don't know i'm just throwing out ideas
by re we're spitballing right here and
again
fanatics.com nflshop.com before uh we
were some for some reason oh
the subject of stanley cup and drinking
out of it to come up you know uh
i imagine you have done that twice
correct because jared stahl your husband
is
one couple of cups right do you have
anything you know any good stories with
that
one once oh yeah once i was uh i was not
in the picture
in 2000 okay we got introduced actually
um that that off season so great off
season for jared stole he won the cup
and then he met his future wife
um you know if i but it's fun i will say
the stanley cup and i can say this
you know very candidly it brings the
freaks out like we took that puppy back
to saskatchewan where he lives and
there were people coming out of the
woodwork just to hold that thing
um we feel bad for the guys now i hope
tampa bay makes it tonight to play the
stars in the stanley cup finals but with
all the worries about coven it's like
jared's like nobody's gonna care they're
all gonna be
drinking out of it there's no protocol
for that and i hope not oh my god
so yeah because and again the the
concept is it
whoever you you can't drink it has to be
tipped to you by somebody who's wanted
right is that
is that the is that the protocol for
this to drinking out of the cake it is
the protocol
and you can't lift it up over your head
unless you want it i mean i've lifted it
up with him but
you know we've been at parties with it
and some some weirdo comes and tries to
lift it and they're like no no no
um yeah they're very serious i mean i
know where
teammates have dropped it indented it
kind of like gronk style and they keep
it into another room
and uh yeah i mean it's it's the holy
grail it's the best trophy out there
it really is well uh in the meantime uh
be safe
enjoy being at games even though you're
in the minority
the rest of the country's back there
watching best to troy and joe and
everybody else at fox and
have a great thursday night season and
sundays and we'll be watching yeah i
miss you hope we get to see each other
right back at you thanks aaron you take
care of yourself at aaron andrews
on twitter also on instagram whereby ea
on instagram as well fanatics.com and
nflshop.com
is how you can get that in a whole bunch
of schools no uh
no syracuse i don't think yeah we don't
deserve it
but they do have georgia if you want to
get one get something free
now we're talking no you just went
higher register which means you're not
interested
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here